doing josh i'm good how are you
really great man uh this is
your f when's the last have you when's
the last time you did a tv show
20 years i believe
what what brought you back now
it's a different medium it's not like it
was it's not like you know i mean
had i been offered
network tv i don't think that i would
have necessarily done it because i'm
just not
as interested there's a lot of shows
that i like to watch
but i'm just not interested in that
energy of being on set because in my
memory of it it was just throwing out
content as quickly as possible but this
is a different medium you can kind of
pick what works best should we do this
in eight episodes should we do it in six
is it is it best to tell it and you know
what i mean so it it's a it's a very um
it's uncharted territory for a lot of
people including myself and we're all
still trying to figure out what exactly
it is
but uh i always like to be in the mix of
something that's uh there to learn you
know
you had to have known deep in you that
you fit so well in this sort of
western ranch cowboy kind of world huh
i don't know if i if i knew i fit in it
i mean i knew i i know
i know the west i appreciate the west i
appreciate the western genre i
appreciate all that stuff but every role
is a totally different role if i'm doing
true great like you don't expect that
dude who has that voice and that it's
just a very strange deal so
you know for me this was fun to get into
because of the metaphysical aspects of
it and the fact that it turns the
western genre on its head and it takes
the hero and totally strips him there
and vulnerabilizes them and
all that stuff is very interesting to me
at this 54-year stage of my life there's
uh there's two kinds of people there's
people who are fascinated and will run
towards the unknown and then there's
those types of people who want nothing
to do with the unknown what kind of guy
are you
oh i'm definitely the first i'm
definitely the prior you know i i i
enjoy learning but and and i subject
myself to mincemeat in order to
um
earn my stay and you know which is a
perfect like parallel to this show i
mean it's a very very interesting
premise to me
it can go a lot of different places it's
dynamic behaviorally
but the what we dealt with in the
elements
you know was we were working nights it
was eight degrees out it was freezing
cold you could barely get it through a
scene without shaking wildly and then
two months three months later it was 106
degrees during the day
so
it's it's you know i don't know why i
like putting myself through that kind of
torture but i do
before i let you go i asked everybody
else in the cast if there was a void who
in the cast would be the most likely to
dip their toe into it and they all said
you
all of them
yeah all of them yeah
wow that says a lot about me man
uh josh you are great in this show the
show itself is a fantastic
congratulations man we should start a
band look at us i don't know what we
call ourselves but i'm just like
thinking that like we got something
going on here we're like
we're about to drop the next hot country
record you know what you're like
i know and i know what you look like
behind that beard i can tell
uh yes exactly silver fox says you are
the man thank you so much i appreciate
your time
you